hi I'm Nick Gillespie and I'm here with
my reason colleague Matt Welch we're the
co-authors of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America and
our next question on ask a libertarian
day comes from thrown softly if that is
his or hers real name is there a wildly
successful modern real world example out
there someplace that showcases
libertarianism at its best yes yes a
thousand times yes
New Zealand stopped giving subsidies to
farmers in the mid 1980s the world
didn't collapse in fact their farm
industry is healthier than ever they
explored a ton they've decreased the
amount of land that they use it is an
environmental success it's something
that every country especially every rich
country should have done ten years ago
but haven't Portugal decriminalized hard
drugs what happened there was a bunch of
junkies in the streets crawling around
no the number of people who were
seriously addicted to hard drugs
decreased if you want to look no further
for a libertarian success go to a bar
and order a beer for crying out loud
twenty years ago all beer in this
country was horrid and now beer is good
and part of the reason why beer is good
it's because in the 1970s Jimmy Carter
deregulated decriminalized the
production of beer in your own basement
and a whole generation of craft brewers
revolutionized the entire beer industry
as we know it I would like to point out
that the decriminalization of drugs of
portugal is probably the fourth Fatima
miracle in that country some more props
to it and also look at cyberspace where
they're in fits and starts we have seen
the creation of a whole new world with
new rules new regulations and it works
pretty damn well
so yes Toronto flee there are wildly
successful modern real-world examples
out there where the principles behind
libertarianism have worked tremendously
well
you